let's bring in a California GOP
congressmen Devin Nunez ranking member
the house Intel committee remember the
Ways and Means Committee I don't know if
he can play guitar I probably can't
there's a lot of things but congressman
thank you so much for joining us on this
Easter weekend we want to go to Capitol
Hill where you guys are the president is
talking about what he wants a targeted
small business package maybe a payroll
tax relief infrastructure bill what's
possible what do you guys evening for
here
well the real need that Senator
McConnell tried to get passed on you
must consent this week was just a plus
up to the Paycheck protection program
this is the program that's loaning money
to businesses so they can continue to
pay employees so that they don't have to
go on the unemployment rolls wanted to
load it up with a lot more junk which we
know they did last time you may recall
they plussed up money for the Kennedy
Center and now look last time I checked
it's not being built into some Hospital
to handle kovin patients so look it's
unfortunate but at this point I think
the key is gonna be when do we get the
country back to work and and parts of
the country go back to work we're
starting to see states like Texas
they're gonna develop their own plan
hopefully other states will follow suit
along with cities and counties so that
we can get America back to work and in
the meantime we just need to make sure
that the programs that we passed a
couple weeks ago are fully funded so
that the American so that every American
that wants to participate in the program
in fact can you mentioned the importance
of you know getting America back to work
as soon as possible the president says
that he's assembling another task force
that's focused on reopening our economy
in your opinion who needs to be a part
of that task force what type of minds
well what I would say on this is is that
the best the best way we can handle this
is closest to the people so
recommendation it's a federal government
stepping in where we can whether it's
through this paycheck protection program
or whether it's with
masks and other equipment ventilators
that we but the way we're gonna fix all
of this in the long run is be able to
handle these outbreaks quickly so one of
the keys to that is gonna be making sure
that each at the county level or the
city level depending on the size of your
county or the size of the city that you
live in we need to make sure that
there's a place that everybody knows
that if you if you come up positive with
the virus that you can go to that
facility if you need to be either one
tested or two if you have to spend some
time in the hospital what we do know
about this now is that it's a it's a
very contagious virus probably one of
the in modern history probably most
contagious viruses but at the same time
you know a lot of people don't have to
go to the hospital which is a good thing
so even though we're prepared for that
now in the long run we're going to have
to look at what are those plans the
local level and look Pete knows a lot
about this you know it's we need to look
at this a lot like a military operation
which people would be very familiar with
yeah the congressman let me jump in here
first thing it does because you talk
about responding and I want to take you
a little bit to the World Health
Organization because it appears now that
have they declared this a pain to make
earlier had they not been telling us
that human to human transmission wasn't
possible according to Chinese scientists
that we could have responded quicker now
there are calls for the head of the
w-h-o to either resign or testify where
do you come down well look all of these
organizations they all they're all do
good organizations they all have they
all mean well the problem is is that
they become very bloated and very
political I actually toured the world
World Health Organization many years ago
and quite frankly I walked out of there
saying my god oh we never have a
pandemic because I don't think these
guys are going to be able to handle it
challenge we have here is it looks like
they're taking the side of of China in
this and you know look I'm not trying to
be anti China or anything like that the
mainstream media want to try to accuse
people of but look the Chinese Communist
Party is definitely responsible for all
of this and along with the World Health
Organization who essentially acted as
kind of abating and letting them do this
in not doing their actual job and I
think the American people expect for
people to help be held accountable
especially the amount of money that we
send there every year Amy
very quickly just to follow up on that
because the timeline is undoubted will
Congress be taking action will you seek
to take action to hold the whu-oh
accountable well you've heard the
president that he says he's gonna
withhold funds he can do that he has a
right to do that Congress should be
supportive of that however you know
we've already seen remember the
Democrats control the House of
Representatives so you know they can
they can block but I think that all
Republicans are united that we want
answers number one from the World Health
Health Organization and number two we
want answers from the Chinese Communist
Party yeah it's shocking that that would
not be bipartisan congressman the
Democrats wouldn't want that to they say
they want a 911 style Commission it
ought to be about the Communist Chinese
thank you for your clarity on that I
want to get your comments though
Laura our own Laura Ingraham did a
three-part interview fantastic with with
the AG William Barr and one of the
things he talked about is there's
there's something far more troubling
about the Russia investigation watch
what he had to say we'll get your
response what can you tell us about the
state of John Durham's investigation my
own view is that the evidence shows that
we're not dealing with just mistakes or
sloppiness there was something far more
troubling here and we're gonna get to
the bottom of it and if people broke the
law and we can establish that with the
evidence they will be prosecuted this
has been behind the headlines because of
coronavirus but what do you know sir
well we just saw last night there were
there were read actions that were
finally revealed to the american Pete
so there's footnotes that now the
American people are beginning to learn
more you know that the House Republicans
have sent over eight criminal referrals
to the Attorney General we
expect those to be monitored looked at
evaluated we know that Durham is is
running this investigation but the key
is going to be you can you build the
evidence in order to make prosecution's
against the you know there's a whole
bunch of folks that we've referred right
with the eight referrals that we've done
but I would say that people should go
and look at those footnotes that are not
public okay because likely we're gonna
have more criminal referrals based on
these and so what we know now the bottom
line is what was revealed last night is
that we know that that the Democrats
were spreading disinformation Russian
disinformation which we had been saying
the whole time it never made sense that
you would take it would have a political
operative like the Clinton campaign
working with fusion GPS hiring a foreign
former foreign spy that they know is
supposedly getting information from
Russian Intel folks you know that's that
doesn't pass the straight-faced test
interesting a lot more to come the work
continues Congress in Devon units thank
you so much for joining us on this
Easter weekend thanks